[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير متابعينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفات هذا المساء
يدعو بوتين لزياره بلاده خلال هذا العام
العلاقه الصينيه الروسيه شاركت وتعاون فقط
منافسه وصراع مستتر على النفوذ
بالله
سابقه تاريخيه واختبار صعب هل يصبح ترامب
اول رئيسا امريكي يتم اعتقاله واتهامه
جنائيا ام انه سينجح في قلب الطويله
لصالحه
وفي النقاش ثالث هل ودائعنا في البنوك
امنه وهل ازمه المصارف تم احتوائها ام
مازال الوضع غير جيد
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول الرئيس
الروسي ونظيره الصيني يوصلان محادثتهما في
موسكو مع تصدر التعاون الاقتصادي المركز
الاول في نقاشات اليوم الثاني من الزياره
التي تستمر ثلاثه ايام وقبل بدء جوله
ثانيه من المحادثات مع رئيس الروسي قالت
اجتماعه برئيس الوزراء الروسي ميخائيل
ميشوستين قال انه دعا بوتين لزياره الصين
هذه السنه في الوقت الذي يناسب الرئيس
الروسي ميخائيل ميشوستين رئيس الوزراء
الروسيه توقع ان يبلغ التبادل التجاري بين
بلاده والصين المئتين مليار دولار بنهايه
عام 2023 يتزمن هذا مع تزايد شهيه الصين
للنفط والغاز والفحم من روسيا تحديدا مع
بدء الحرب الاوكرانيه لتقفز وارداتها
باكثر من النصف ووصل انفاق بكين على طاوله
او الطاقه الروسيه الى ثمن وثمانين مليار
دولار في فبراير الماضي وفقا لارقام
الجمارك الصينيه بالاضافه لان موسكو تعتبر
او تعتبر مصدرا عسكريا هاما
تطور العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه يفتح الباب
امام تساؤلات عن طبيعتها فيما اذا كانت
شراكه الاستراتيجيه حقيقيه ام انها تميل
الى التكتيك
علاقه الصين بروسيا استراتيجيه ام تكتيك
بعد عزل روسيا بشكل واسع عن اوروبا وجهت
موسكو اقتصادها نحو الصين
اما جورنال فرات ان الاقتصاد الصيني
والروسى متكاملان حيث تصدر روسيا الموارد
الطبيعيه للصين وتبيع الصين لروسيا ما
يحتاجه المستهلك الروسي
فرانس بريس اشارت الى ان عواقب اضطرار بيع
روسيا نفطها للصين باسعار ارخص من المعتاد
تظهر على ميزانيه موسكو
الباحث في معهد شنغهايلد دراسات الدوليه
في الصين شاولونغ قال ان العلاقات بين
الصين وروسيا بعيده كل البعد عن كونها
كتله متجانسه
واشارت المسؤوله السابقه في البنك المركزي
الروسي الكسندرا بروكو بينكو الى ان
اعتماد روسيا المتزايد على اليوان يجعل
روسيا اكثر عرضه للاجراءات الصينيه في حال
تعثر العلاقات بين البلدين
تقول ان التاريخ الطويل والعنيف نسبيا بين
روسيا والصين ترك ارثا من عدم الثقه
الرئيس الصيني قال ان روسيا والصين جاران
جيدان وشريان موثوقان
فيما صرح الرئيس بوتين بان الدوله لن
تضعفهما السياسه الامريكيه العدوانيه
نعمل على تطوير شراكاتنا في كافه المجالات
سواء التجاريه او الثقافيه وايضا شركاتنا
على المستويين الاقليمي والدولي بالامس
وخلال عدد من اللقاءات والمباحثات قمنا
بتبادل وجهات النظر حول مسارات التعاون
وسبل تعزيزها ولقد توصلنا الى نتائج
ملموسه في علاقاتنا المشتركه وايضا حول
سبل العمل على تطويرها وتعزيزا
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا صحفي تشاوشي
جون اهلا بك وبعد قليل مفروض سينضم لنا
كذلك من موسكو تيمور دويدار الخبير في
قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه اسمح لي
ان ابدا معك سيد تشاو في الواقع لفهم هذه
العلاقه التي يراها البعض متقاربه فترات
ومتباعده فترات اخرى بين روسيا والصين
سنبدا بتصريحات الرئيس الصيني رئيس الصيني
في كل مره لا يتحدث عن شراكه استراتيجيه
ما يستخدمه كمصطلح هو شراكه شامله هل
تعتبر الصين بان روسيا شريكه حقيقيه
استراتيجيا ام ان الموضوع محدود الموضوع
مؤقت بحسب ما تطره المتغيرات السياسيه
شكرا على دعوتكم طبعا
الصين
شريك استراتيجيه وشامله
الرئيس
الصينيعه مع رئيس
تم اختيار روسيا كاول دوله يزولها لان ذلك
يتوافق مع المناطق التاريخي ودعا الرئيس
رئيس
وهذا يدل على مكان في روسيا الفليده في في
[موسيقى]
صينيه ومن المعروف ان هناك
تعاون
وهذا يدل على ثقه السياسيه متبادره بين
برادين وبالتالي اعتقد ان تعاون بين بلدين
في مجارك اقتصاديه وتجاره وسيم صحيح ولكن
سيد تشاو ما ودت فهمه لو سمحت لي هذا
مفهوم وتابعنا طبعا تطورات هذه الزياره
لان الصوت يتقطع سيد شاو
فهمنا كل هذه التصريحات طبعا ونحن نتابعها
ونتابع هذه الزياره المستمره لثلاثه ايام
ولكن سؤالي الصين كيف تنظر لهذه الشراكه
مع روسيا الى جانب الجانب الاقتصادي على
المستوى الاستراتيجي تعلم حضرتك بانهما لا
يلتقيان لا تتقاطع المصالح في ملفات عديده
لما كانت روسيا في الشرق الاوسط الصين
كانت
تهتم اكثر بملف تايوان بالمحيطين الهندي
والهادي فبالتالي لم تكن هناك مصالح
مشتركه هذه الفتره هل تغير شيء ما
اعتقد ان من المعروف ان العلاقه بين دول
معقده دول بين علاقات بين دول معقده
للغايه وطبعا
اكبر قوه مجاوره لبعض
من المستحيل
عنها
فان
المستحيل الالات مدافسه بين البلدين وكل
دوله لا تريد تذقيه بمصالحها وتريد حمايه
مصاريها وهذا الامر معقول
ولذلك يجب عن تكون هناك منافسه بين روسيا
والصين وكما هو الحل في المجال الاقتصادي
وتجاره
ونفوز في في اخرى مثلا الشرق الاوسط ولكن
الشيء المقيم هو ان هذه المنافسه صحيه او
منافق
عادله ونظرا لوجود اساس من الثقه متبادله
بين السن وروسيا
اي من طرفين او غبات اقتصاديه على الاخر
او
يفني
رسوما جمركيا او ينشر الشائعه في المجتمع
الدولي لمهاجمه اثاره في الاخر وخيلها ولا
ترفض السين هذا النوع من المنافسه الصحيه
التي
بانها منافسه مشروعه بين دولتين وهذا
مفهوم ولكن في المقابل عن هذا التقارب
اتحدث مع حدود الصين لدعم هكذا تقارب
بمعنى حضرتك تعلم بانه اليوم الغرب يسلط
عقوبات قاسيه على روسيا الصين تحاول فتح
منافذ لمساعدتها بين الفينه والاخرى ولكن
الصين شريك استراتيجي للغرب هل يمكن للصين
ان تخسر شركتها الاستراتيجيه الاقتصاديه
مع الغرب لتقويه بوتين
يعني بالنسبه لبكين
سين تقوم بسياسه خارجيه عدم شراكه وعدم
الانقياز في لا اعتقد ان هناك تحالف عسكري
بين السجن وروسيا ولكن
يبدو بان فقطنا
ساعود لك بعد لحظات اسمح لي على المقاطع
الصوت يتقطع في الواقع حاولنا فاهم
المعنى الاجمالي للكلام ولكن ساعود لك بعد
قليل بيض جاهز معنا ضيفنا من موسكو تيمور
الاداره الخبير في قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات
الدوليه اخيرا استاذ تيمور بتجهز معنا
لتكمل معنا ما تبقى من هذا الملف من
مناقشه هذا الملف في الواقع طرحت على ضيفي
سؤال يتعلق بنوع العلاقه الصينيه الروسيه
في هذه المرحله وحضرتك تعلم بان الطرفين
لطالما سميا بالاخوه الاعداء هذه المرحله
مع
تقاطع المصالح كما يرى مراقبون بدرجه
متقدمه هل تغيرت نوع هذه العلاقه
تقصدين بين الصين وروسيا كذلك
يعني السياسه السياسه المتبعه بين روسيا
والصين من الجانب الروسي
استخدام الصين كشريك في استهلاك
ونعني هذه الكلمه في استهلاك الموارد التي
لدى روسيا
كانت بمثابه
في
يعني في العلاقه بالاسواق الدوليه وطبعا
اهمها الغربيه الاسواق الغربيه هنا نتحدث
عن الموارد موارد الطاقه اساسا ثم الباقي
الان نشاهد ليس حتى الان يعني على مدار
فتره طويله
حتى قبل بدايه الخلاف الكبير مع الغرب في
توغل الصيني اصبح
بمثابه ليس فقط بث نفوذ وانما ممكن ان
نستطيع القول بالتورغل في روسيا وربما حتى
البعض يسميها الاستيلاء على روسيا
فتعدد الصينيين كثروا كثيرا في المناطق
المضخمه هي الحدود الصينيه
الموارد الروسيه تستغل بطريقه احيانا
عبثيا عندما نتحدث عن مثلا قطاع الاخشاب
وكل ما يعني ذلك وثم انتقلنا للارقام مثلا
يعني شاهدنا
الرؤساء يتحدثون عن
شيء
انتصارات كبيره اقتصاديه لكن لم يتحدث احد
عن التنمويه
ولكن استاذ تيمور السؤال يطرح نفسه صحيح
ولكن سؤال يطرح لماذا تقبل روسيا بذلك
لماذا تقبل بان تخرج او على الاقل تنفصل
من نفوذ غربي لتدخل تحت طائله نفوس صيني
هل بقيت الصين الوحيد
هذه سياسه الحريه لروسيا يعني نعم
والاداره المنتخبه من قبل الشعب الروسي
فممكنًا نسمي ذلك سياسه روسيه لكن في
روسيا رؤوس ينتقدون هذه السياسه لاننا
نفتقد للتنميه عندما نتحدث عن العلوم
والتكنولوجيا وكلما يخص التنميه
المقاومات
للدوله
الحديثه
والغنيه في هذا العصر
الصين تاتي لنا بموارد ماليه يعني مثلا
بالنسبه لروسيا من ضمن 850
ذكروا ان
حجم المعاملات التجاريه بيننا وصل ل 1990
مليار دولار
171 لناس الصادرات روسيا الى الصين
واردات من الصين الى روسيا من
الصادرات الروسيه
85% هذه السنه الماضيه 22
شكلت ال85 مليار كانوا
فحم زيت
وغاز
من الصين لا ناتي باي تكنولوجيا او اي شيء
بالمقارنه ب 2014 مع فقد الاتحاد الاوروبي
كانت حجم عملتها 400 ما بيننا بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي 400 مليار الدولار من
التكنولوجيا واستثمارات في قطاع الزراعه
ليست العبثيه
البعض يعني انا احاول ان اكون ابقى الى
حلقه قادمه معكم ربما البعض يعتقد في
روسيا ان
[موسيقى]
الصين ونعم فعلا ربما شريك سياسي
واقتصادي في حين نحن بالنسبه للصين الذي
بلغت الصادراته ثلاثه وسته تريليون دولار
نحن في حدود ثلاث بالمئه لا هم لا شيء
لا نتحدث عن شراكه استراتيجيه تكنولوجيه
او تنمويه هو على فكره استاذ تيمور حتى ان
تنمويه ولكن حتى رئيس الصيني لا يتحدث عن
شراكه استراتيجيه دائما كان يستخدم مصطلح
شراكه شامله بما تحتويه من مستويات
كثير عده مرات
شراكه استراتيجيه تحدث ولكن مراقبين كذلك
يستخدمون مصطلح الشراكه البراغماتيه
الصينيه اود سؤال ضيفي من بيكين سيد تشاو
حول هذا الموضوع هل ترى في هذا التعامل
الصيني الروسي او هذا التقارب الحالي
استغلالا صينيا لروسيا كما وصف الاستاذ
تيمور او ان هذه هي
الصين هذه هي الشراكه الواقعيه التي
تتخذها دائما الصين مع من تسميهم حلفائها
بالنسبه لبكين
يعني
ربما في مثلا على سبيل المثال في قضيه في
ازمه اوكرانيه روسيه وليس لها سين اي
مصالحي في هذه الازمه ولكن
سلام بشان هذه الازمه
وتدعم الصين
المحادثات السلام في هذه ازمه
الصين وروسيا
تتمتعوا بعلاقه استراتيجيه شامله وسين
ولدا سين وروسيا الثقه السياسيه متبادله
العميقه بين البلدين
في خلال هذه
موضوع خلال هذه القضايا الساكنه دوليه
سين تريد ان
تحاميل مسؤولياتها عن حفاظ على نظام
مجتمع
دوليه على
النظام الدولي ولكن هذا عكس ما نراه من
تصريحات الصين الصين دائما على الاقل هي
وروسيا تتفقان حتى وان كان تختلفا في
العديد من النقاط ولكن تتفقان في موضوع
وقف التمدد او توسع الغربي
والخروج من طائله النفوذ الامريكي كيف
الحفاظ على النظام باختصار شديد
بالنسبه لدول العربيه لا شك عناقه لا تريد
ان ترى عزيزه المستمر للعلاقه بين بكين
وموسكو ولكن بالنسبه فان زياره رئيس الى
الى الى روسيا هي مجاعه تبادل طبيعي بين
البلدين وكان معنا الصين لا تقتاموا
بكيفيه تفسير واشنطن دول الغربيه لهذه
زياره لان اداره بعيدا
انتهزم بنشر نظريه التقدير من الصين
وكما قلت انا سن في الحقيقه ترحب
بمنافسه صحيه
بين الدول طيب وضحت هذه الفكره ان كان لك
تعليق سيد دويدار باختصار انت كرمت
مصالح سياسيه
اولا ثم عسكريه هذا من من جانبي لان
التعاون العسكري او الكتله ليس الحلف لكن
الكتله
العسكريه الصينيه الروسيه تدعم بعضها
البعض في
التحديات
السياسيه والتي تحل الان عسكريا في العالم
فلذلك ان كان ليس التحالفا لكن هذا تكتل
وتكاتل يقلق حلف الاطلسي ويشكل له تهديد
نعم على كل نحن سنبقى في متابعه هذه
الزياره وسنتابع كذلك المتغيرات التي ربما
ستاتي بالجديد وشكركم من جزيل الشكر من
موسكو تيمورت ودار الخبير في قطاع الاعمال
والعلاقات الدوليه بكينا صحفي تشاوتشي جون
شكرا لكما